I don't believe someone's gonna pay me
for anything unless I give them Value
First why can you still sell after
giving away free content the more I give
the more opportunity I have to sell the
more people I can bring in from the top
of funnel with free content the more
opportunity I have to give them to go
deeper with me are there already people
selling things and making money in this
topic that's a general Global like okay
this could be valuable I don't do a lot
of public selling on social media or
YouTube I usually just sell to my email
list so it happens behind closed doors
and it's very targeted and these are
very warm leads
what if there was a way to turn your
knowledge into a thousand dollars or
more per month in just 30 minutes a day
what if there was a better way than
YouTube ad Revenue when it comes to
earning money from your content well in
this episode of the think media podcast
I'm super excited to be talking with
graham Cochran who is a best-selling
author he's a YouTuber business coach
But ultimately he originally launched a
project called the recording Revolution
a YouTube channel that was all about
helping people mix their audio and learn
how to make radio-ready songs and uh it
not only blew up but he was able to
monetize it in ways that the average
Creator and entrepreneur doesn't know
about so buckle your seatbelt because in
this episode we're going to be learning
about how to package what you know into
an online course YouTube tactics and
getting into a lot of Juicy content and
so I'm super fired up but Graham welcome
to the podcast hey honored to be here
man and love what you're doing and
excited to talk shop yes and so I want
to start off with your story to give us
a little bit of context today you're a
specialist you wrote a book how to get
paid for what you know and all about
turning your knowledge passion
experience into an online income stream
in your spare time but what I love about
you is similar to one of my passions and
that is that like you did the thing
before you taught the thing and you
didn't just start like teaching online
courses about online courses but you had
this whole era where you took what you
knew about
recording and uh musicians and all that
kind of stuff built up a channel built
up courses I made a ton of mistakes and
then now you're an expert in all of that
and you can help people scale even more
by packaging what they know into
something like an online course but take
us all the way back to where you were in
2009 and how this all started yeah man I
um it's funny that you have to even like
qualify that because I feel like anybody
can teach anybody how to make money
online these days and that's how they
make money online which is what I do now
but I did do it in a hobby Niche which I
think is encouraging just a side note
that there's plenty of people that will
say you can only make money online if
you're teaching people how to make money
online it's like absolutely false most
of my students are making money online
teaching something other than like how
to learn French how to walk your dog how
to like you know fix motorcycles how to
you know get rid of back pain so anyway
it's a real thing and I didn't know this
world existed until and I didn't even
want to be an entrepreneur to be honest
like I didn't I didn't that wasn't a
world I knew my dad was an engineer my
mom was a school teacher I just wanted
to do music like that's what I wanted to
do I was like the worship leader at
church kind of guy I wanted to be a rock
star I wanted to make music videos and I
was trying to make a record get a record
deal in college and that fell through
and I got married Youngs I had to get a
real job and actually provide and I kind
of let the music dream die so 2009 to
your point I moved with my wife to
Florida we're in Tampa Florida now to
help a buddy plan a church and got a job
we all just moved and got jobs and we
had a first baby we bought our first
house down here at age 26 and then I
lost a job a second job in the same year
in the middle of the Great Recession so
we don't know anybody here except for
the people were planning a church with
and I'm like freaking out and I don't
want to go back to a job I hate I've
been I've already felt like my dream
died years ago and so I thought well you
know what I do have a freelance audio
skill I kind of did that for like a side
hustle for years mixing records for
bands I'm trained in that I went to
school for that I love making records
for myself and I was like maybe I can do
that full time you know there's always
side money but maybe it's this is my
sign to go full time and that's what got
me into actually YouTube because I was
like you know what I need leads I need
clients and I don't know anybody in town
so while I'm trying to network in town
why don't I just blog put up some videos
on YouTube I think I launched my channel
in January 2010. I was like and maybe
someone will see like what I'm doing in
the studio I'll do some tutorials and
here's how I got a kick drum sound
here's how I make the vocal sound like
this and maybe I can somehow get leads
and that was what all I thought I was
going to do was get some leads for the
freelance stuff that's amazing and today
the recording Revolution is now not your
main Channel although with 639 000
subscribers 720 videos what's also kind
of wild is you have passed the brand on
to other creators other Talent which I
think is a massive kind of a it's a
mind-expanding thought because a lot of
times when people think of YouTube they
do think it's limited to themselves if
all they're building is a personal brand
then perhaps that's true but you have
defied a lot of common myths that many
people think before we get into
kind of how you packaged
free versus premium or paid content what
were some of the lessons you learned for
the recording Revolution YouTube channel
to grow to over 600 000 subscribers yeah
I mean there's a couple of things right
I mean I think part of it I was a little
lucky with the timing at that time in
that Niche or that industry in music
production everything was like a guarded
dark secret no one was sharing the how
how do you make records sound good all
the all the big time producers weren't
sharing
um you would be lucky if you got an
interview with somebody
um like Crystal or algae or Dave Benson
or any of these guys that were mixing
you know all the big bands and they
maybe shared a secret but anyone who's
learned audio and figured it out you
know it's just stuff you learn I'm not
I'm not trying to diminish their skill
but it's like I I'm not them but I know
I know how it all works and so I was
just trying to put out the content that
would help my friends who were trying to
figure this out as well and so my
friends was like my avatar their
musicians they want to make a
professional sounding recording they're
not an engine engineer so they think
like a creative brain not a technical
brain they just want to make their music
sound good they don't need to be famous
necessarily they want to know what to
buy what not to buy and they just want
the truth and so I that's what I had in
mind when I made videos and I think I
grew quickly I grew slowly at first so I
don't want to say I grew quickly but you
know maybe 18 months in I started to see
some traction of posting every single
week for like 18 months at that point
started to see some traction because no
one else was sharing the truth they were
talking around the subjects
um or it was really light conceptual
content and I was cracking open the
software you know we use a tool called
Pro Tools which is a lot like Photoshop
but for music and I was like hey here's
how you get this sound here's the tool
here's the step and you could literally
go do it and get the results and people
like who's this guy sharing like this is
so helpful and I was explaining complex
things in a simple way so I think it
kind of helped in terms of I was one of
the first people to really start telling
the truth about music production back
then at least on YouTube maybe people
were blogging about it that helped it
was is also a convergence of the just
like with video right gear costs came
way down and so there was more of like
this hobbyist Market that was coming up
saying oh I can I can get a recording
studio for cheap and so there was a high
interest in doing music production at
home at that time and and so it was a
perfect time for me to get on and start
teaching all this stuff and teach them
what to buy and it really just took off
because I just kept telling the truth
speaking to real people and I and
something you've talked about before is
getting really clear on who the Avatar
is that your channel is for I had that
dial down so well that I think people
either either liked it or didn't like it
and that made it help help me help me
grow it I think man that's some powerful
insights you know I've heard it worded
this way moving the free line and I
think one of the big things that holds a
lot of people back is they're afraid
especially if they Aspire One Day to
create an online course they're like
afraid of giving away too much or they
get
in paralysis oh like should I share this
or should I hold back and I think
holding back
is a bad strategy you know it'd be like
should I hold back when loving my spouse
like I don't know I just don't want to
kind of love them fully should I save
some for later yeah yeah should I hold
back when loving my friends and maybe
it's a fixed pie thinking too like of
course there could be the idea of you
know are you gonna run out of everything
you have to say but if you continue to
grow and if you realize something like
this is so complex there's you know uh
Nam just happened the National
Association of Mer music Merchants I
spoke there one year for I think sure
and that's in Anaheim there is endless
depth to home studio recording studio
monitor software questions people could
ask
um your top Feud video as well is six
years old 3.7 million views and it's how
to build a home studio core desire for
under 350 which is a radical headline
because 350 is nothing for a home studio
so
um your second most viewed video a
million views recording great vocals in
two steps apps so success leaves Clues
and it's cool to see and then I love
that you said you know it still took 18
months everyone out here is trying to
get viral videos and a gold play button
in 18 days and so just the patient
patience and Persistence of consistent
content and so you start building up
this channel you are very generous with
your knowledge you share real raw gritty
authentic and practical deep tactics
people can use and thus your channel
starts to grow you start to build trust
you start to build a brand at what point
did you package what you know into an
online course and what was like your
first product that you launched yeah I
mean I think you know real quick to your
point
giving you can't give away too much I
don't I don't I don't believe in that
ever and um I've been told many times
like you give away too much content and
I think I'm like I think you give too
little away I think the reason why I was
able to grow is because I gave so much
away no one would care about me or know
who I am if I didn't give so much away
so I've never seen giving away free
content cannibalize paid content just
and I've been doing this for 14 years
and two Brands so it's just my
experience the more I give the more
opportunity I have to sell and people
love it and there's a lot more we could
unpack there as sort of why you can
still sell when you have free giving
content on the platform but I I
experimented with selling content really
quickly because I I realized that you
know what I thought was a way to make
money which was hey I could uh sell
banner ads on my blog you know this is
2009 hey I could you know try to do some
I don't think the monetization option
was available for me at the time on
YouTube it was so early I just started
posting but I had some readership and I
had an email list and so I thought you
know banner ads some advertising some
Partnerships with some Brands microphone
companies you know Speaker Company
companies and I made you know a few
hundred bucks here or there
and then one day I was planning on doing
like a massive series on YouTube on this
topic teaching the software Pro Tools
you know back in the day like I couldn't
upload videos longer than 15 minutes
um and I was like I'm gonna need three
to four hours to explain this software
that's confusing people in a way that I
want to explain it it's like I could do
that as a YouTube series and don't get
me wrong I've done tons of YouTube
series that were super long and
bingeable which is a lot of fun but I
was like this one's going to be so long
let me test something let me see if
someone would actually buy content from
me so I filmed this four hour course I
didn't know it's called a course I just
filmed four hours of explaining this
software chopped it up into logical
sections put them in a zip file got a
PayPal button used iweb on my Mac and
then emailed my list and said hey I have
this thing and I called it Pro Tools
boot camp and I sold it for 47 bucks and
I said basically it's this is the most
popular software in the audio world it's
like here's the best way to understand
it without it being complicated it's not
going to be boring we're going to make a
real song together and you're going to
see how to use this as a musician see if
you want to buy it I didn't think anyone
would buy it and I remember the first
sale I got I was in Seattle I know
you're from that area it was originally
I was in Seattle my grandfather's
funeral
um and it was after the funeral and I
was back at the condo where my
grandparents lived downtown
and I needed to go get some Wi-Fi
because they didn't have internet in
their unit this is 2010
um they're like they don't we don't have
Internet so I went down to their Cafe to
get Wi-Fi just to check email and I got
like a PayPal you have money type email
I'm like who's who's sending me money
you know I didn't have a client it's
only 47 bucks I'm like that's such a
random oh that's the course that I I
emailed up to my list some dude named
Paul bought this ZIP file and uh and
then he loved it and then another person
bought it and another person bought it
and I didn't make much money it wasn't
much of a launch like you know any
Porter field and Jeff Walker would have
laughed at me but I didn't know they
existed and I was like
somebody paid me for digital copies of
videos that I filmed I've already filmed
them now and I could now sell these
videos forever and that was like six
months into this journey for me so it's
very early on I didn't make much money
but that was when I understood digital
products and for I just had the vision
all of a sudden of like oh my gosh what
if I had more courses what if I had uh
more of a bigger of an audience what if
I could sell these at higher price
points and all the above and I just saw
all these dials I could imagine these
imaginary dials I could start to turn up
in this fantasy of a future and I just
got really excited about what was
possible using YouTube to drive leads to
my list to then offer them even more
in-depth paid training and that was way
more exciting to me than ad Revenue well
and
that is um
powerful experience through telling your
story kind of starting with the 1.0
version and now it has grown and
recordingrevolution.com store I'm sure
has had multiple iterations but I see
three different digital products Total
Home recording musical income mixing
University so you've made multiple
products and now you have multiple
businesses as you've continued to scale
but I do want to take it back why can
you still sell after giving away free
content you alluded to that earlier and
you said you have some more content on
that drop that on us yeah this is this
is like one of the best questions that
people ask they should ask this question
if they're trying to sniff out this
business model right because people
think here's what I hear people think
they either think you do YouTube which
is it's all free and you just get this
massive audience and then you make money
off of brand deals or ad revenue or
whatever
or you sell merch or you have paid
courses and and you're thinking about
funnels and digital marketing and then
you just have to drive ads to get people
to buy your thing they view them as two
separate worlds or two separate games
that are being played and I I posit to
you that it's it can be one and the same
yes you could do either and I I'm doing
a hybrid I'm building an audience on
YouTube and and the videos like and this
is why and I send all my people to to
you into think media to learn how to do
video and even YouTube stuff because I
know that when they watch your video
what's gonna happen they're gonna get
educated they're gonna they're gonna
trust you you're trustworthy and I know
you're trustworthy I mean I know you as
a real person but like I could watch 100
of your videos and feel like I know you
and like that's a powerful thing right
so then now if you had something to sell
to me I I already know who you are you
trusty already like you it's so much
easier to sell so I see them as like
these beautiful things to work together
so coming back to your question in my
book I talk about this because this is
one of the biggest questions I don't
think anybody would read the rest of the
book if we didn't address this early on
of like okay well if I'm gonna be making
free content and giving it away
um in something I call the value Circle
I talk about in chapter two then how am
I going to still sell the thing I mean
people are very confused and so I think
the content
is your marketing engine it's what gets
you discovered that's why YouTube is so
powerful right it's a it's a massive
search engine you can build Authority
and credibility people can test drive
you they can go watch a video of yours
and say wow I did what Graham said and
it worked or I got the results he must
know what he's talking about never have
to give me a dime you can test drive my
knowledge test drive my thoughts or my
experience and if you like me and and
you want to go deeper then why would you
buy something from me why would you buy
a course on mixing if I just taught you
how to mix on YouTube well the reasons
are in my opinion and maybe you have
some more too Sean is like I think one
an online course or a paid Community
let's just say online course you can go
way more in depth in a course it just
the the vehicle it allows for
little like deeper deeper deeper dive
into certain things in a 10 minute video
even a 20 minute video even a 30 minute
video on YouTube I have to hit a bunch
of things that can be valuable but I
can't go as in depth as I want to and
there's other videos I'd want to put in
a course that aren't going to be
clickable on YouTube they're not going
to serve the algorithm it's just but it
really you need to know this so you can
go more in depth it's curated
information the more people get on
YouTube and I welcome everybody get on
the platform this room for everybody but
the more people the more overwhelming it
is because there's so much more videos
many more videos and where there's
overwhelmed there's opportunity right so
if you're overwhelmed just take my
course because it's step one through
twenty or It's A to Z everything you
need to know in one place just log in
and you can just go linearly I'll hold
your hand to the process people are
paying for that curation they're paying
for proximity to you because inside my
course now you're a customer and now you
can like in a kajabi backend or
teachable or whatever you use you can
like leave a question under a video and
I'm going to answer your question
because you're a customer I can't answer
every YouTube question I mean guess I
could but I just don't have the time for
that kind of thing I want to live my
life so you get the priority response to
from me because now you're in proximity
to me as a customer I can have more
downloadables and other you know assets
that help you learn it and you know
people pay attention when they pay they
people who pay pay attention and there's
that psychological thing if they're
going to dive in because they paid for
it they're going to get results so all
of those things come together and that's
just with a course if you have a
community element to this thing well
then now you can get into my private
community and now you can talk to my
other customers who are going through
courses you can talk to me you can add
live coaching elements to it behind a
paywall where you can really deep dive
so people I think are going from far
away your free stuff to closer maybe on
your email list where now they're
hearing from you regularly to really
close if they buy a course of yours
ultimately to any kind of coaching
relationship they're paying for
proximity to you and I think we're in an
age of people finding the teacher they
like finding the personality they like
and wanting to pay to not just have
access which sounds like weird
prostitutional thing but like I will pay
to get closer to an educator or a
content creator Who I Really respect and
I want to learn more and I want that
person to actually know my name too
which is kind of I want to be in
relationship a little bit um and so you
pay for proximity and that's the
powerful thing of the more people I can
bring in from the top of funnel with
free content the more opportunity I have
to give them to go deeper with me and
I've never seen it cannibalize we've
experienced the same thing and those are
some powerful insights I'm sure the
listener is dying to know though you
mentioned the value Circle and so in
chapter two of your book it's give cell
over deliver receive just give us a
little bit of a breakdown of what is the
value Circle and what are these four
touch points what are some nuggets
around them yeah so if I explain my
business on the back of a napkin that's
what I would draw draw this circle and
the top of it says give and then to the
right sell the bottom receive and then
or over deliver and then the fourth one
is receive and in the middle of the
circle is the word value so what drives
a good business is not is not really the
widget or the course it's the value that
it it imparts and usually that value in
our type of world comes in the form of
transformation people aren't buying
information they're not buying a course
they really want to buy transformation I
want to lose 20 pounds or I want to be
more productive or I want to
um have a better marriage you know I
want all these things that take you know
these are transformations I want in my
case is I want to make my recordings
that go from sounding like crap to
sounding professional and like proud of
sharing it with my friends or putting it
on Spotify or now I'm teaching people
how to launch businesses I want to go
from a nine to five I hate to like
having a flexible business that's six
figures a year and 20 hours a week to
run or whatever it would be that's a
transformation they're buying and so I
have to give them value at every point
in the journey so I don't believe
someone's gonna pay me for anything
unless I give them value first and so I
like to lead with generosity so that's
why I'm big on content I've outsourced
and and automated and eliminated almost
everything I can in my business except
for valuable content every single week
that's truly good and I and I think
about it like this piece of content
might be the only video of mine or
podcast of mine or whatever that they
interact with I want to make sure it's
it's life-changing even if it's in just
one percent life change so that their
interaction with my brand was really
valuable and positive if I do that well
for free that gives me the right to then
sell them something or offer them
something it's maybe a better word and
then what I offer them better be
valuable as well like I better have a
product that's even better than my free
stuff because of all the things we
talked about and it gets people results
so you don't want to bait and switch
them and sell them a piece of crap you
could but you won't be in business for
long once they find out so you give
value for free you sell something
valuable and they're like wow this is
totally worth what I paid for it and
then you over deliver you give more than
they thought they were gonna buy you can
do this in a lot of different ways I'll
sneak in like a mini video training on
the welcome page of a course and they
buy it I'm like hey I didn't tell you
about this but I have an entire training
on X that I wanted to give you as a gift
um and and blow their minds I saw
Brendan Bouchard do this years ago he
had this really powerful training after
I bought a course of his and I was like
oh my gosh this is this is even better
than the course like I didn't even know
this was in here it wasn't on the sales
page wasn't a bonus it was a over
deliver and you can see companies do
this all the time big and small ways
even Sweet Water right you buy I buy
audio equipment from Sweet Water and
like my kids know Sweetwater not because
they care about audio but because
there's candy in the box when it comes
there's like Smarties and all these
candy and that's that's not like a major
thing but it's the little thing of like
oh man they put someone put candy in the
box and it just it's a beautiful
experience so you give value you sell
valuable stuff you over deliver with
something valuable if you do those three
the fourth part of the value circle is
then you will receive value you're
already going to receive money if you
sold but you're going to receive
testimonials you're going to receive
people sharing your brand like you've
got to follow Sean you gotta check out
think media this this guy's awesome this
stuff is awesome and then that gives you
the opportunity the both the money and
the testimonials give you the
opportunity to keep giving away stuff
for free which is now you're back to the
top of the circle and that allows you to
sell so you can see how they all kind of
work together to stay in business and
you don't want to go out of business you
just want to keep the circle spinning
and spinning and spinning so you need to
sell so that you can give and you need
to give so you can sell and it all kind
of circles around value it's a beautiful
framework and so
our community is listening to this and
they've made the decision okay I've
committed to YouTube and I'm getting
views I'm getting subscribers or I'm
just starting but I'm also trying to
build out my business plan and think
down the road of what will I sell one
day or what which piece of my knowledge
will I package or perhaps
we have many people in our community
that are still not they're on the fence
not even because they're hesitating
because they're still in the planning
stage they have multiple topics they're
thinking about I want to start a Channel
about this or pivot my channel towards
this and we do emphasize a lot of
clarity is power reverse engineer first
every battle is one before it's ever
even fought if you're gonna go into
business and you want to quit your
corporate job or you know go part-time
or be able to do this full-time it's
smart to start with the end in mind so
what is Step One is find your idea and
you have a profitability framework
sometimes people struggle with online
course because it's maybe not position
right they make it but the it's crickets
it could be a marketing problem but but
breakdown how to actually come up with a
profitable online course for those who
may have the misconception of yeah if I
build it they'll come you know what will
people even want and why would someone
even want my online course so so what is
the profitability framework yeah so
this is the most important part
um because what I'm teaching is like not
just how to have a a big YouTube channel
right that to me it's a means to an end
like it's a tool
um because what I'm teaching is how to
build a business which really helps you
build the life you want so it's I bet
it's important to understand the role of
everything so if you start with end in
mind to your point which is I want to
make a sale I want to sell something so
like I can have an income then you have
to like anything you have to have
something that the market values and so
part of what we talk about in that in
that chapter of the book is you know
start selfishly like just what what do
you love to talk about what you love to
do what are you good at what are you
passionate about what have you had
experience with I don't like to use the
word expert or expertise only because it
paralyzes people I don't I never I
haven't felt like an expert I I didn't
feel like an expert when I started the
recording Revolution I knew a lot about
recording I was just sharing what I knew
you know that could help people I didn't
feel like an expert when I started a
personal brand business coaching but I
had a lot of success you know selling
stuff online and building a business and
I could share what I what's worked and
what hasn't worked so you get rid of the
expertise language but you maybe create
a list of you know all the things that
you could talk about on YouTube or could
build a channel around that you would
enjoy and my you know my list would
include football Star Wars Pizza you
know really nice hotels you know travel
um you know my faith it would include
you know family stuff it would include
personal finance and investing like all
the stuff I dork out over just look
whatever my my library is in the books
behind me it's like it would include all
these different things and you could
make the case that any one of those
could become a business I mean people
are making money probably off of every
single one of those niches but you start
with what you love and what you're good
at then you have to then take that list
and filter it through the lens of is
there an intersection where one of these
or two of these or three of these line
up with what people value and will pay
for is there a market for this and this
is not as complex as it sounds right
like this is our gosh are there already
you know books being sold on this topic
if there's books being sold on Amazon
lots of them around the topic then you
know a major publisher has already put
money into the market research search to
say I'm going to print books and push
this author because we think we can make
money they've done the research for you
if there's you know Affinity groups on
Facebook or YouTube big YouTube channels
around this subject all of these things
are good indicators that you know
there's a market here the more saturated
the better I think because then you it's
proof that you can make money in this
market if it's hyper Niche we don't see
anybody doing it it could be either
amazing because you're the first one and
you're gonna crush it or it's a really
bad idea because nobody really wants to
to buy a course on how to iron your ties
you know like there might be some Niche
it's too small so if to be safe look for
are there already people selling things
and making money in this topic that's a
general Global like okay this could be
valuable and then I I really think what
makes it even more important is drilling
down to real people what do real people
say about this where are they getting
stuck what are their real dreams is
there a Gap in the market that you could
come in and be more specific around
um and so what I want to get to is just
like the concept of you're in YouTube
land so I think you've got people that
and you I don't want to put words in
your mouth they're already excited about
YouTube want to do YouTube see the value
in YouTube I get a lot of people I'm
having to convince to do YouTube because
they want to jump to I want to sell a
course I want to have a paid Community I
want recurring Revenue I want passive
income and I'm like okay what are you
going to sell I think a course on this
great do you know anyone's going to buy
it or do you have anyone to sell it to
and they don't yet and so I'm trying to
convince them why don't you build a
YouTube channel first
and start to create content and see if
anybody cares and not only do they if
they care figure out what part of it do
they care about like every video I put
out is a test to see which which topic
is really the hot button issue that I
should probably pay create some paid
material around and I don't know that I
can guess but it's really the
interaction with my my YouTube audience
and then my email list if they go deeper
to figure out okay what could I help you
with more what do you if I could give
you results in the next six months what
that you would want what would they be
and if I could coach you one-on-one what
would you want me to help you with and
if you start to see Trends and patterns
then you get a better clue of okay in
general I help people make recording
easier but more specifically what part
of it do they want the most help with
and that's a better way to then go build
a course because now you basically
you're extrapolating from your YouTube
data of what people like and just going
deeper on that subject otherwise you're
you're guessing and it could be an
educated guess but I'm not that smart so
that's how I see those things working
out is start with your passions and
interests see if there's a market for it
drill down what specifically do people
want out of that and that's not as as
fast of a process as maybe we would like
you're very familiar with
the YouTube world and then of course
your core way you serve and help people
today is you help people package what
they know and turn it into a course and
learn all the gritty details
um and uh and really so you understand
both I'm just curious some stories from
your community people you've helped of
some examples of online courses that
maybe might be surprising to our
listeners
um or that might be kind of interesting
and that might help stretch our thinking
into just what's possible and what kind
of online courses people will actually
pay for yeah so this is fun right I have
a student named Lane he was a pastor and
he started a YouTube channel and a brand
called preaching donkey and he wanted to
help pastors preach better sermons and
so he started with an e-book he was
writing ebooks um and he wasn't you know
he maybe would sell like a thousand
dollars worth in a month and that's when
he found me and was really kind of it
wasn't necessarily me but figuring out
maybe it shouldn't be a book maybe I
should have like a course and some more
paid things and so he he started working
on towards that end so he built out his
book idea into a course and then
multiple courses and then a paid
community and then he got some
one-on-one coaching from that so he's
gone from maybe a thousand dollars to
two thousand dollars a month with an
e-book which which is pretty consistent
to doing fifteen thousand dollars a
month now consistently he moved to the
beach where he wanted to live in Florida
and his wife stays home now and works
with the company and so it's him and his
four kids and his wife living in in the
panhandle of Florida 15K a month and
he's working you know last time he
emailed me a couple weeks ago maybe 10
to 20 hours a week
um and it's all started by helping
pastors preach better sermons I have a
student named Ico who teaches native
Japanese speakers helps them better
pronounce their English so think about
like business Executives you know um
actresses and actors who are trying to
come into the English market and they
already speak English she's not teaching
them how to speak but they're trying to
get rid of the accent a bit and
pronounce English a little bit better
and so she was making a thousand to
three thousand dollars a month hit or
miss doing some coaching
now she's doing 30 000 a month she's
built out a framework she has a funnel
she sells everything from a membership
to a course to cohort coaching but they
find her through YouTube and then they
go deeper with her and she's got a tiny
it's a tiny Micro Niche but she has she
charges really high prices because it's
such a unique group of people who are
like I you're the only person that does
this and I need this help in my business
career or my acting career or she has a
couple of athletes now that want to move
to the states and play baseball and so
they want to speak better English or
pronounce it better so she's doing like
30k a month and then uh I've got I got
students that teach not just guitar but
ambient guitar right like how to like
how to do ambient guitar well which is a
style of guitar playing with delay
pedals and all this kind of stuff which
is to me super niche as a guitar player
like I I'm like how could you build a
channel around that but he's got a
channel called ambient guitar Academy
and he's built that into a six figure
year business and he works about 10
hours a week Max and now he takes
Fridays off he's got his son and it's
just it's gone from fledgling like can I
do some videos to
a framework a system to now take these
leads from YouTube and build out
consistent income wow one of the things
these are stories are so inspiring but
one of the themes that I also love is is
there's a lot of values alignment with
our community because people want to
maybe not just have freedom from the
thing they're doing now but family is a
value faith is a value and no doubt
about it setting things up takes work
building some things out takes work and
this all takes work but to here's the
stories of doing it 10 hours a week 12
hours a week being able to take Fridays
off once you have some of the automation
pieces here or especially this is why we
also love online courses at think media
is because building it is one thing but
once you've created it you now can
create it once but sell it multiple
times and uh you know we've updated our
core YouTube course a few times so
there's we Circle as the globe spins
around we've probably rebuilt it about
four times and certain industries also
shift more like YouTube has updates and
saying all that the dream is this
lifestyle that it creates and the
freedom that it creates and so in just a
second I do want to
um dive even deeper into the income
engine and talk about these four focuses
that you can focus uh in a business like
this and so
um we'll get there in just a bit but I
do know that listeners may be at a place
where they're ready to package what they
know into an online course and they are
looking for that step by step and so I
definitely want to let everybody know
you've got a class
um we made it easy to get to at think
income1k.com that's the number 1k.com of
course we'll link it up in the show
notes this is all about how to generate
your first a thousand dollars a month of
passive income in just 30 minutes a day
and learning the four steps to create a
Dependable online income
you're gonna get a lot more nuance and
detail there so check that out in the
show notes and we'll of course also link
up so much I want to talk about in the
pages of Graham's book how to get paid
for what you know but that's of course
available on Amazon as well and so that
will be linked up in the show notes talk
about
now the income engine
so there's so many pieces how do you
build that how do you structure it how
do you do that and and people can follow
you and learn all of that but the course
is done now so what is the income engine
and what are these uh these four steps
yeah so one of the questions I get is
okay Graham I built a business and I
built the course and I maybe I've
launched it and it's out what next what
do I do every day that's like the
question I get so what do you do it's a
funny question
um but it if you get to that point
that's a huge accomplishment for one to
like have launched your business
actually put a product out there in the
world and even if you made a hundred
bucks like you did it now what and so
the way I looked at it I was try to
answering this question over the years I
realized man there's four things that
I'm still doing every week in my
business and so that that's what I call
the income engine how do you keep this
thing spinning and have the better
chance for things to grow right because
I think momentum theory is a real thing
that a given enough time if you're
delivering value and you're consistent
enough time you will gain momentum a
video will pop you know something will
happen you can't control some of those
things but what do you do in the
meantime and so it's really simple the
system that I teach is is like really
basic but it's like you need a lead
generation machine and so I believe in
content marketing meaning I don't run
paid ads and I never have so I'm not
spending money on marketing it's all
free but it's my time right but I really
believe in the power of content
marketing so if you've ever thought you
have to do paid ads I'm a good test case
I've done two seven figure businesses
and I didn't run paid ads for either of
them so it's possible not saying you
can't but you don't have have to but you
need leads and so I'm teaching content
marketing so that means every week I'm
creating new content and it to me it's
at least one piece of content a week one
main YouTube video we could split that
up into some reels and some other short
form content or chop it up one main
video podcast or something like that per
week so the more content you put out you
never give up doing that because that
feeds the engine and that's how you got
started in the first place
the second piece of the engine is
growing your email list so as much as I
love YouTube and I don't think it's
going anywhere and I think you probably
agree
um I I want to get people off of YouTube
onto my list right because I own the
list if I just build up a big Instagram
following or a big Tick Tock following
and then Instagram gets no one cares
about and Tick Tock gets banned from the
US government and then YouTube shuts
down you know then I have no access to
the audience I've worked hard to build
so I want to make sure that it's not
just on YouTube but I want to invite my
super fans like hey come deeper with me
and that's a big part of what I teach in
the book is like how to create lead
magnets that get people to want to leave
YouTube and join your list and why would
they want to and what does that look
like but the list is important because
that's who I'm ultimately selling to I
don't do a lot of public selling on
social media or YouTube I usually just
sell to my email list so it happens
behind closed doors and it's very
targeted and these are very warm leads
and they convert better for me so I
always want to be list building always
and I'll do that even like even in my
book if you read my book right at the
back of the book there's a giant opt
like lead magnet hey do you want this
entire mini video course 30 day training
go to grahamcocker.com whatever like
there's a lead magnet in the book
because I don't have their email address
even if they read my book and want them
on my list so I'm always list building
number three is real quick I'm always
nurturing that list you don't just build
a list and just sell to them you know
they're still your people you're still
you're there you're still leading them
and teaching them so most of the emails
I send are just valuable free content
going back to the value Circle I'm I'm
teaching them new stuff I'm sending them
to my latest YouTube video I'm like I
noticed something in the news that's
interesting and relevant I'll send it to
them
um I'll like if I'm on this podcast with
you I'll let my people know about you
know your podcast you should check out
this great conversation I had with Sean
like it's always nurturing every week
minimum popping into their inbox staying
top of mind and let even if they don't
open your emails they see your name yeah
that gram guy is really that's super
helpful that's super helpful so you're
not always selling you're just adding
value nurturing most of the time and
then the fourth thing is well you built
the course you can build more products
too
you know like there's way more you can
build it could be a second course it
could be a membership Community like a
paid Community it could be a a group
coaching program with 12 of your best
students you take them through and
you're real close working with them it
could be one-on-one coaching it could be
a weekend retreat that you're hosting in
your city it could be hey I launched a
book you know you should read my book it
could be anything
um you know one of my my buddies ramit
Sethi like he just launched a Netflix
special right he's gone from like
blogger to he's on Netflix now so he's
going to use his email list to hey guys
watch me on Netflix that's technically a
product he's getting paid by Netflix to
do a show but he's using his list to let
people know about it so it could be
anything but that's the four things it's
content email list building nurturing
the list and coming up with new products
and building out a legit product Suite
because there's just so much more you
can offer to a variety of different
people at a variety of different price
points wow and if we take it back to
recording Revolution how many products
over the years have you had currently
there's three available publicly on the
store and today you've got all kinds of
ways you serve people helping especially
like people in the think media podcast
Community packaging what they know into
an online course but back when you were
doing that but doing it for learning how
to learn recording learn mixing or build
a home studio
how many products over the years did you
create in that business yeah probably
like 20 you know wow and did you retire
some of them I mean uh have some maybe
they were archived or updated yeah yeah
some kind of disappear like they weren't
that great some like I had one little
mixing course uh called rethink mixing
and it was a 99 course and it was not
created in HD it was it was it was not I
didn't think very technically great it
was just me like mixing a song in front
of you and I just chopped it up that
thing has made me over a million dollars
just was one little 99 course it just
kept selling for seven years and I kept
saying I need to update it it looks so
fuzzy and crappy I could make it better
but it kept getting such amazing results
for my students that I almost felt like
there was something magical about I
don't want to touch it so I left it and
let it run in my funnel for uh for I
never had a big launch never launched
well but it made me over a million
dollars over a seven year span that one
little course and I eventually just
cannibalized it and made mixing you know
diversity which is just a whole nother
ball game but I was like I'm gonna let
it run as long as I can but yeah so some
things I phased out and replaced some
things I created collaborative courses I
mean going back to what I was saying at
the beginning when there was no music
producers teaching the Dark Art of
recording in the in the mid-2000s it's
funny come 2015 I had I I would go to
Nam every year I started to get to know
a lot of producers and they needed
alternate forms of income you know the
record labels were drying up streaming
is really cannibalizing music sales and
so they have fewer clients to mix these
are these are like my mixing Heroes like
making the biggest records and and they
started to have conversations with me
like hey you got a big audience could we
do a course together and split the money
I was like yes we could so I made
multiple products with multiple big name
producers where we would film them
teaching their thing and I would sell it
to my audience and we would split it
because I had the marketing machine the
leads and the trust and Goodwill and
they had a name that was famous and we I
created a ton of products that way and
made them a lot of money and I made a
lot of money and it was a lot of fun and
so yeah we've made a lot of different
things over the years and one other
thing I will say is the platforms these
days that you can use to sell your
products if they're courses like kajabi
I'm a kajabi evangelist so I'll keep
saying kajabi but there's lots of
options what I love about these tools is
you can have products but then you can
have offers that are separate meaning
you can get creative and say look it's
Black Friday I want to take my three
most popular courses bundle them
together and call it something new and I
did that with like five of my best
products I called it the radio ready
system it wasn't a new product it was a
bundle of my five best products at 60
off with a shiny new thumbnail and I
just told them like look this is my five
best products it's a whole system that
thing started to sell so much better I
had a higher price point but it was
really just me repurposing and selling
some different stuff in a different way
and it's just so easy to do that and get
creative with your offers over the years
with these kind of tools so it's a lot
of fun in just a second I want to learn
what you feel like some of the habits
disciplines and your kind of final
thoughts about
the traits of successful people that
lean into this business model but before
we get there I want to remind everyone a
couple of things
um and that is that there's obviously a
a thousand nuanced points to uh learn
about all of this and so uh definitely
check out the show notes uh Graham's
YouTube channel over 50 000 subscribers
a lot of nuances about building your
email list and writing copy and and how
do you host all this stuff and so he's
got a ton of free content there and he
also has a deep dive class that you can
check out at think
income1k.com or we'll just link that up
in the show notes and so I highly
recommend if you know you're ready to do
this and actually I recommend watching
that regardless because it's always nice
every battle is one before it's even
fought reverse engineering and and
thinking through even if you're not
ready to pull the trigger right now
thinking through okay where's this all
going and how am I setting this all up
and how am I positioning my YouTube
channel my content and we we talk a lot
about picking the right Niche or the
right topic because once that's that's
huge if certain topics are do not align
as well with actually packaging things
into a digital product later so to your
point depending on what your aspirations
are it's good to think things through
and so
um definitely check that out that free
class that Graham
um has for you is that think
income1k.com that just simplifies a link
for you to get there and you can check
that out in the show notes and then
Graham I have that final question for
you in a second but if people want to
connect with you where can they follow
you online and everything like that yeah
the only social platform I spend time on
is Instagram so at thegram Cochrane you
can hang out me there or on YouTube hit
me up yes and so uh all of this will be
summarized in the show notes but Graham
I am curious now that you've been able
to serve particularly entrepreneurs
creators you know some terms that we
love around here
is content preneurs YouTube preneurs and
uh infopreneurs is kind of one of the
words of somebody who takes their
knowledge or their information and turns
it into a business and uh YouTube
creators entrepreneurs small business
owners this would be our community but
specifically for people that figure out
how to thrive like your pastor friend
and student who has now got this thing
down
to 10 uh to 12 hours a week able to uh
serve people help pastors preach better
and also spend time with his family has
created that freedom people like him
what are some of the habits disciplines
or traits that that are necessary for
success or lasting success in this
industry I think the the greatest
greatest
trait you can have in almost anything in
life is is discipline to keep showing up
I mean it's it's so overstated but it's
underused I mean people are looking for
a shiny thing or something it's just
it's an excuse to not just do the thing
that's in front of you I've never known
what I'm doing right I'm figuring it out
as I go I've always felt like if you
hear the term imposter syndrome I always
feel like I don't belong here like I
eventually someone's going to find out
that I'm just Graham I'm just the guy
you know and when I started my business
like we were broke on food stamps I had
a baby and I'm I'm in my spare bedroom
making videos writing blog posts
tweeting out starting figuring out how
to host a website on WordPress in 2009
and the plug-in plugins and and feeling
like oh my gosh I'm just Graham in the
spare bedroom broken on food stamps like
that's that's how I felt while I was
starting out and um and so even though
I've had some some like success that
makes me feel like maybe I know
something I thought the feeling would go
away and it hasn't and so there's this
element of well I'm still going to show
up anyway and I'm not going to quit like
I felt early on and I think I developed
this because I couldn't control much
about our finances back then I was so
desperate to make money I was like I
can't control anything other than I'm
going to show up every day I'm going to
get in my office and I'm going to create
something that's valuable for somebody
put out there in the world and hope it
helps and hope isn't really the best
strategy but it turned out that content
creation that's valuable and showing up
consistently was good and so I was
probably stubborn enough to stick with
it even though I probably could have
quit multiple times and had a wife who
supported me which when I wanted to quit
so I really thank her a lot
um so I think you have the discipline to
keep showing up because so much of this
business is we've talked about is
figuring it out like figuring out your
messaging figuring out your take on
things get when you get a little more
confident on YouTube You Realize
especially if you're in the education
space but I think it's true even if
you're in the entertainment space on
YouTube getting more polarizing in a
good way like just putting a stake in
the ground and saying this is what I
really believe and You can disagree with
me and not having to be a jerk about it
but just being confident people are
attracted to that that content does
better but that took me a while to be
confident to sort of stick some stakes
in the ground so the discipline is huge
and then the big thing though I see the
biggest mistake I see some of these
people making and my students too
eventually if they listen to me enough
they know like my philosophy and they
either like it or they don't but one of
the biggest mistakes is just trying to
make a lot of money that's actually not
that hard if you stick in the game long
enough like in YouTube some of the stuff
you can figure out how to make money
online you know what's harder and more
impressive is how to build a great life
and build a business that takes care of
your income needs but you also have time
to take your kids to school pick them up
go to church get enough sleep you know
like go to the gym wash your minivan
like whatever like have time for friends
it's have a vacation and the business
still run without you that is more
impressive and not hard but it's more
intentionality is needed and so what I'm
trying to teach students is don't think
about oh I want to six figures yeah and
six figures and I want to what work how
many hours do you want to work how many
days do you want to work have you ever
thought about taking Fridays off and
making it a family fun Friday or a date
day with your wife or like have you
thought about some of these things
because if you think about some of those
things there's tools and strategies to
help you not just make money but make
them within these parameters of you know
what I'm going to draw a line around my
time around my schedule around the type
of activities I'm willing to do and you
can still make a lot of money in these
type parameters and I think a lot of
people just never stopped to think about
it and so they're just thinking about
one goal which is reaching my income
goals without the lifestyle goals and
both can be achieved powerful insights
and man it's so inspiring to talk to you
because of really values alignment and
the idea of having a greater Mission
that's bigger than money and then the
idea of not giving up once you want most
for what you want now you know I always
I think I stole a quote from Larry
Osborne which was If I gain
the Applause of the crowd but I lose the
love and respect of my children I've
failed you know if I make a lot of money
but I blow up my marriage I failed and
uh of course with deep empathy for our
community I know all kinds of stuff can
happen in our life and in our marriages
and our families and maybe sometimes
lessons that we learn the hard way that
can always help us reinvent and uh you
know press on into the future with
greater wisdom but you and I are both in
all kinds of circles and we speak at
events where we do get around people
we're in the green room with some people
where it kind of could be scary I hear
some people say you know if you're if
your wife and kids aren't on board who
cares you know it's like we're going
forward anyways like we're uh you gotta
just chase your dreams you gotta cut
loose dead weight and there is stuff of
like about your circle and about
different things but at the same time
um I think that ambition
a lot of people get messed up with this
people of Faith especially get messed
with this they think ambition is a bad
thing no it's not that ambition is a bad
thing but toxic ambition is a bad thing
oh that's a whole episode I'd love to
have man just that's near and dear to my
heart for sure yeah it's a real thing
and it's and actually you could be on
either side of the spectrum where you
could be on the side of the section
where some some people need more you're
like actually it'd be really good for
you to get some ambition and maybe to
capture some god-given vision and have a
little bit of a drive but for some
people given to uh you know get letting
getting disconnected from their core
values ambition could lead you to the
wrong place and potentially lead you
away from the things that matter most so
I I am so grateful for you and respect
you Graham and grateful for all that
you've shared there disciplined to just
keep showing up and then really thinking
about what are your deepest values that
you can actually align what it is you're
building around Graham of course we have
all those resources that we highly
recommend in the show notes Graham
Cochrane I want to thank you for coming
on the think media podcast